[Music]
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talon's white kid president trump and
the democrats around the demagogues
around the world but i tell him if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump and you ain't
black we choose truth over facts
i want to be clear i'm not going nuts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strange
[Music]
delicious i'm coming in a little hot in
my own ears but that's because i uh i
have a i have allergies do you yeah and
so my ears are all poppy you know i had
someone
just offer me
no one knows about that farm i had
someone offer me a boatload of money to
sip tea
for the acemer they call it the kids
what's that i don't know can you guys
let me know comment below what's the ace
mer
spelled a s and uh m and then an r and
they were asking me to do this
the whisper yeah they were going to send
me like tokens
i don't know
i don't know i think it's just one guy
they're weird drink my smear yes it's
just the two uh sisters from my thousand
pound life
whatever they produce whatever when they
sit next to each other yeah they clean
up on on webcam people pay to watch uh
watch them eat like whoppers and stuff
so uh in case you hadn't already
realized that society's broken look we
have a lot to get to today the theme
today is is comedy dead now john oliver
will talk about him tomorrow but he does
basically imply that comedy is you know
was dead under trump which i disagree
with but we are going to be addressing
jordan clepper i know some of you saying
he
works at the daily show
and went after the canadian truckers and
i think there's a certain look i have no
problem with someone having a point of
view in comedy but when does it devolve
into propaganda i think we've reached
that point stephen colbert trevor noah
and we'll also be talking about bill
maher bill maher taking some stances
that should not be considered
controversial catching a lot of flack
for it yeah so finally coming around uh
it's interesting to see comedians right
now this is a this is a time in history
where i can you know i'll talk with dave
about this really quickly actually even
off the top i can't remember a time
where comedians decided to
kick
protesters demanding freedom while
they're down
no that's that's not the realm of comedy
i mean if you go back and okay lenny
bruce was uh more liberal sure okay bill
hicks classical liberal the idea that
comedians would join in to demand the
government silence
voices of dissent that's a really really
weird time in history as a matter of
fact it's the only time
in human history that i can think of and
obviously stand up as a uniquely
american art so uh before we move on if
you miss us on youtube
every monday through thursday rumble or
mug club 10 a.m eastern
10 a.m eastern and we're gonna put a
pull up maybe that's apt to change
because of people in pacific uh
complaining about it we have a whole
additional hour of show today on mug
club uh and my question of the day
let me ask you this do you watch any
late night comedians anymore
any late night hosts at all comment
below not including yours truly and we
used to do this at night we just did it
in the morning because we realized that
nobody watched it at night they watched
in the morning oh just move it around
technology changes things along with the
acemir all right you know him gerald hey
how are you i am well sir how are you
i'm feeling well i'm happy to be here
yeah yeah sound good happy to be here
and fight for our constitutional
republic there we go and uh he's got to
do it more so point out the the hackery
it's it's bothersome uh and you know him
you love him and i'll be on tour with
him actually uh may 14th in tulsa
oklahoma june 18th in pikes peak
colorado that's colorado springs
colorado if you want to see these shows
they sell out really quickly so get your
tickets now lightweight.com tour and
dave landau how are you ahoy i'm good
yeah and memorial weekend uh i just went
through this yeah uh big elves in emily
minnesota i'm good the back of my head
hurts why did what did you do back to
your head i s i fell ice skating yeah oh
is that what we hold on
yeah he's got a snopes fact checked on
this he was like gerald yeah i was ice
skating and i was doing really well
right up until i cracked my head on the
ice i'm like that's not doing really
well no that's the opposite of doing it
yeah
i mean if you bend your knee after you
do a pole vault you know your score goes
from a ten down to a two so if you
smashed your cranium on the ice that's a
that's a solid yeah as you know the
judges kept giving me nines and i
thought it was because of my low-cut
dress and it turns out it wasn't but i
brought my son and his friends we were
all ice skating and
uh we're in livonia and i went my son's
friend fell so i went to him then my son
fell
and my body's like i'll take care of
both these things so both my legs fell
out and then i flew back and somehow my
entire body went in the air and i just
cracked my skull
on the ice but there's there's a silver
lining to this he got recognized did you
leave blood on the ice it looked like
fargo uh no fortunately i wasn't
bleeding which a lot of which was my
first question to the many people that
gathered
and then i was
i walked into the uh
uh i don't know skate rental shop and
the guy goes do you do you know stephen
crowder and i go i do and he's holding
his head the whole time wanting some ice
and he's like
you look like a comedian on there i'm
like i am i am the comedian i'm there
i'm also in pain yeah
he goes no you're not and i go i i am
i'm dave landau could i have some ice
please and he's like he's like well
there's plenty you just fell on it
yeah i swear to god he goes
no you're not like no i still i really
am dave lando
he's like show me some id and i'm i'm
like not even really i'm so full i
didn't ask you to vote i know i'm so
foggy i'm like here's my idea what i'm
thinking in in you in normal life that's
usually a good out for me where i'm like
no i get that all the time so i don't
have to talk to someone right so i'm
like no i'm showing someone my id to
prove i'm me while i'm just waiting for
some ice and somebody's like is that
like dave and chuck the freak i'm like
no that's local radio this is like an
internet shirt
i just need some ice please
gonna get an aspirin somebody oh well if
it's a school uh nurse you can't get an
aspirin but you can get a bowl of magnum
condoms
what if you have a long lunch hour yeah
why do you have a long lunch hour yeah
what do you think about that you've
never needed a if i had a long lunch
yard i would still only need one what's
the matter with you guys also i don't
wanna know why they're bringing magnums
because that's why we still have a teen
pregnancy problem look
leave your ego at the door just like
dave at the skating rink yeah nothing
worse than renting skates at a skating
rink like you can skate except for the
the blades he was like hey do you think
you can skate on butter knives no no i
don't think i can well and the two kids
he was trying to help he actually killed
when his skates came down on their torch
and by health he was actually uh passing
out candy asking him to come to his
paneled van no the two kids uh my son
and his friend who needed help i ended
up in way worse condition turns out they
were fine
by comparison it turned out i was way i
am the one that had to wake up every
hour i think i twisted my ankle back
there yeah it's bad when you can just
hear everyone in a rink scream because
of the sound of your head and it echoes
yeah it's the opposite of you know if
ever you were to dispose of a body in
the wintertime is great because snow is
sound dampening yeah
ice the exact opposite different thing
yeah
just the screeches echo like a banshee
he heard his wife screw up the
recreational center oh thank god oh he's
still alive he's moving yes i just heard
he has somebody going like cha-ching for
insurance money
are you in good hands no i'm not i'm not
all-state at all oh is he getting up
rats
all right here while we move on and to
talk about comedy here today uh
okay this is from sorry dave it's
colbert off the bat we're gonna be
talking about colbert we're gonna be
going to comedy central and we're going
to be going to bill maher and what's
interesting is seeing how they all cover
the events of our time
it's just it really is disturbing
because we used to believe that it was
sort of the last bastion of free speech
it's not anymore because you have to
look at late night comedy and then a lot
of these comedians who are beholden to
this these late night sort of circuits
they have to be careful with what they
say if they want to get their air time
it wasn't like that with johnny carson
it wasn't like with johnny carson or
even dave early david letterman where
people say hey hold on a second if you
said something unpopular at the chuckle
hut we're not going to book you so it's
interesting to see them all toeing the
same line with the exception
of surprisingly now bill maher who of
course is catching hate he's been
labeled a right-wing extremist which is
what he labeled us
a year ago so first we'll go to colbert
uh and uh
if you're white and you hate if you're
white and you hate
period but if you hate yourself
specifically you might find this sketch
funny uh even then i doubt it let's see
what 40 writers and 19
000 emmys at colbert can do do you find
it difficult to talk about race yeah
nope unsure what words might offend
others definitely
we've turned discussing black history
into a fun party game
wait awesome what
introducing taboo white fragility
edition the game that lets you discuss
black history without making because
they couldn't just poke fun
into slavery that's a book at the
airport uh all right no problem they
were a famous abolitionist
seriously yeah it's on the card okay how
about they fought against injustice oh
sorry saying injustice implies that
there was injustice there was i feel
like this game makes you know less about
black history
can't say black what do you mean i can't
say black
i'm black
[Music]
you told us we couldn't see so this is
like critical race theory handbook from
the public school curriculum and they
just said let's make this a sketch
pretty much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
taboo white fragility edition from the
makers of we're not sorry
well they couldn't possibly have used a
straight african-american no i uh
did somebody look at him and go this is
terrible and it's like well we can just
do a buzzer over most of it yeah yeah
exactly that'll fix this yeah wow that
was awful i need more buzzer what was
the joke the joke was white people are
dumb and bad oh
people enslaved the mediterranean when
you look from north african slave
traders a million a lot
a lot the british were late to the game
okay
they got there when they could yeah the
north africans where hipsters are like
well we were enslaving people before it
was cool
yes but also chinese that's pretty much
all we can afford you find a paper cup
what we got here that's why we're very
good at soccer
please
bye my friend brandon i know you think
it's all knuckle puck in east l.a like
mighty ducks too but we can't actually
afford that equipment that's not true
you know what after i hit my head on ice
i kept thinking about knuckle puck for
some reason and how upset i was like
there's no street hockey no there's a
mystery it's honestly
i kept thinking about that i kept
thinking of keenan thompson hitting a
knuckle puck and i was getting mad or
they went into the local basketball
court in east l.a right to set up trash
cans to play hockey where they would
have gotten their asses kicked by the
actual street ballers
it's knuckle puck time now it's mine now
you're getting a knuckle sandwich [ __ ]
we're about to shoot for three no this
is a basketball court
[Music]
hey but fortunately
dave's memories are coming back and he
does remember being assaulted by a
priest now yeah i did immediately that
was the first thing i first think it
unlocked the vault i guess unlock the
repressed memories
also the pathological intoxication i
told you about that robitussin that is
true so name that movie reference you
can name it balloon uh here's something
else another story before we've got a
lot to get to on clepper and bill maher
um science now is making meat
out of thin air so this company air
protein has found a way to turn carbon
dioxide
into meat that that's that sounds pretty
stupid well initially i thought like
yeah that's what everyone wants everyone
wants someone's beer farts turned into
their food yeah i've heard like the soy
thing so you're actually saying now
they're trying to make meat out of thin
air like is this some like bill gates
like mind voodoo trick that we're seeing
what the hell is going on yeah well no
you're thinking like no they're not
going to turn
okay so you misinterpreted the art you
said they make meat out of thin air yeah
they're no they're not making it's not
like bill gates making burgers it's a
it's a
different yeah it's a different kind of
meat
dr patch adams
here you've been
you've got a trouser snake living in
lake flaccid yeah that's right dr adams
uh i've taken all the medications and i
still can't get an erection why don't
you have a seat young man all right
have you tried sleeping with better
looking women
or men no judgment oh
just if you're feeling a little light in
the loafers no doctor i like woman you
see the problems the problem's not that
the problems that i have this stupid
refuse to harden penis that just refuses
to harden well good news oh i have just
the remedy for mr happy ho ho have you
ever heard of bonzo
bonzo
it's an air meat erection medication
some good wood to lumberjack
how does it work doctor beats me but i
think you beat it is it safe no
yeah doctor thanks for this but uh if
you don't mind me asking
why are we uh in an alleyway i got me
tooed last year this is the only place i
can practice medicine
bonzo may cause popping itching fancy
flippers skittles break dancing multiple
sclerosis in wuhan bats hat wearing
holocaust denying anal explosion and
pregnancy in men make her monzo with
bonezone bonzo is not 100 fda proof i
don't know how they dealt with carbon
dioxide who are we god let's stop
playing god
[Music]
it barely works no i mean no it never
works i thought you're talking about the
sketch
we just we have a robin williams
impersonator on retainer yeah like we're
like we really haven't gotten our
money's worth hey look jim sciutto right
now on cnn decided to dress up wonderful
good for him yeah you know what put on
that hood and walk through the streets
at night see what happens he's in
ukraine give him you know that's why
they dress right yeah that's interesting
you see you see how far away he's in the
furthest western portion of ukraine
possible right he's in the lviv yeah
he's just got his like one foot in
ukraine yeah he's like i'm here sort of
like at the four corners he's like hold
on now you told him yeah
let me through
so this actually brings us to something
in international politics which i don't
usually like to discuss but this this is
worth it so russia you were saying
they've reported what they've increased
their troops yeah so they've they've
definitely increased their troops
they've done uh nothing to slow down as
cnn is telling us right now nothing to
slow down it's like 190 000 at the
ukrainian border 190 000 even after
saying troops were leaving and releasing
videos that apparently weren't actually
real right yeah with tanks leaving that
right that's cool so uh here's something
interesting though completely irrelevant
to that uh tensions are obviously high
and on friday a fight broke out between
a journalist i want to make sure i'm
getting this name correct and ukrainians
you guys can comment and let me know uh
yuri butusov and parliamentary deputer
uh parliamentary deputy nestor freak
on the ukrainian television program
freedom of speech so that's nice they
have that show oh good so i've attacked
sufric
they fight on shows and uh
this guy is a pro-russia member of
parliament okay to be clear and uh what
happened is i guess he refused to condem
vladimir putin okay and so we're going
to show you the whole clip so you see
this in context and you see just how
different
it is that governments function abroad
compared to the united states uh and
then we're going to do a fight
play-by-play breakdown because that'll
give us some insight into the
geopolitics so here you go fight on
ukrainian television
yet
we'll do a breakdown after this
[Applause]
ground and
please just just one kiss yes just one
listen we don't have to repress this any
longer don't spoil it we've been holding
back for so long let them know
i don't know what i did to deserve you
but somewhere in my youth let's go to
heterosexual men's power all russians go
for some reason yes but uh let's make
sure not beth house that fauci is always
he'll look at me sideways and make me
uncomfortable he says disease is
airborne that's right but i don't
believe so because you get it by
injection from me man with glasses knows
to stay out of it yep yep she knows that
we will kill family in russia you get
one pair every 10 years that's right
so there's a lot that went on there and
it's time for uh this week's flight
breakdown
[Music]
so let me explain this so that's this
way i can translate it because a lot of
people especially if you're listening on
audio yeah first off i apologize that
you're listening on audio because this
makes no sense
visual show by the way if you're on
youtube smash that like button right now
smash the like button it helps with the
algorithm and it pisses off the youtube
overlords if there's you know what five
five thousand likes
in the next five minutes uh behind mug
club we will do an entire segment on the
inbreeding of the royal family dave and
i oh okay an entire segment on the
inbringing of the royal family there's
gotta be five thousand likes in there i
don't know how we'll be able to find
evidence yeah i don't know
you'll give it away exhibit a through z
and then a through z 25 more times
exhibit a and exhibit a i'm just talking
about the bloodline right yes and then
we exhibit a 42
so now we go to kiev for the highlights
i'll explain to you what actually led up
to this the actual translation so let's
play it here
so tempers start to flare when he uh
he's asked to condemn
there's a russian agent right here in
the studio
the guy with the glasses if he shaved
his beard would look exactly like moby
yes so here it comes oh boom right there
pause it okay keep it there right there
that so it starts with the lead left
slap to the face that was open palm very
russian very russian
left slap that's what they call that's
what they call the moscow slap you don't
want to hurt the knuckles see but you do
want to make contact also it's more
disrespectful yes yeah it is and that's
really the point yeah you you want to
treat him like a russian gal yeah yes
yes exactly i treat you like gullag
[ __ ] yes you lady tina turner i'm male
i that's it you are like gulag concubine
yes who says i care about your pleasure
i don't i get smile now read for mine so
this happens okay we're gonna continue
playing in most places you would say
that's the end of it right here in the
states like okay assault you call a good
lawyer with a lot of vowels in his last
name that's not what happens here we
continue all right continue and the man
responds with
look he gets up looks at him and bing
look
right there okay so been in a fight you
can tell what happens is he then leads
with sort of a modified uh jab really
more of a lead right straight because
he's standing in a south paw position
which by the way a little known fact
more ukrainians are southpaws really yep
i have no idea so
it's the water listen this is a
following along in other words if he is
not we need to find this out if he is
not left-handed he's leading with his
power hand okay he decided i want to do
some this is not a slap he's boom he's
sticking that he's he's got some snap on
that right there you go you know he's
pulling a little bit of that pernell
whitaker actually he's got his hand up
okay now we continue and the fight
continues to escalate there's definitely
bring in the south paw though right
there right there now a knock down okay
so you would think this guy has the
upper hand this is the beauty of
politics and civil disagreement
[Laughter]
because
the man on bottom
has a disagreement which we will see
right now as we continue this man is
underneath he gets up and look boom
reverses it with a modified body lock
takedown i don't know what you would
call it it's sort of yeah it's just knee
judo effectively at that point and uh
let's continue because the fight
continues on
and uh of course the most interesting
part here what this is hyperly technical
getting to side control neon belly uh
and very important
this gentleman right here is just
sitting like he's
doing nothing sitting by a fireplace
yeah he looks like he paid them to do it
right yes more yes exactly and we can't
see his right hand either so we have no
idea how much he's enjoying fight for me
like you used to before i was
permanently in this chair we're going to
have tryouts i'm leaving now he's
continuing here he's holding him in a
modified scaffold
they're all trying to separate them
think about this they cannot separate
these men this is how much these guys
hate each other
this guy holds public office
and uh you can take me off the box there
uh uh tim because uh keep playing what's
really most impressive continue playing
is that this translator
just never
she's just like i don't know what to do
uh and now she starts translating the
cussing at each other like you will be
my [ __ ] yes
i will make you scream my name look
she's still translating that lady is a
trooper and you know what i'd give her
an hb1 visa
[Laughter]
all right he had the chokehold going
though he was indeed oh yeah he was he
was get he was going this guy has some
fight training and that translator i
tell you what she's been in some
domestic abuse situations because her
cage is not rattled whatsoever what i
love about this is it's every real fight
in the world because when you watch a
movie you think it's awesome real fights
are you two rolling on the ground like
jackasses and everyone's embarrassed
especially you right yeah and that's all
that happens but they're still talking
trash yes oh like the guy on bottom is
like i've got you right where i want you
yeah yeah
as he's being now try my face to your
fist style
hurts doesn't it oh yes oh i'm going to
strike your knee with my nuts
[Laughter]
yeah the guy who kind we got to say
cheap shot at him and then ended up
getting knocked down with a southpaw by
an old man then he reversed he did i
know but still still the point is they
both got their licks in they did and
this is how
disagreement should take place that's
how democracy works i don't know if they
have democracy in ukraine this has been
this week's fight breakdown
[Music]
what's also funny by the way i should
note
the panel discussion it continued after
oh really yes
and sure even mocked buddhism for quote
scratching like a girl please right
imagine that just sitting back down he's
like
okay yes yes sir you scratch like a girl
oh anytime i'm easy to find so about the
border troops i think that we have to
yes yes i'd agree he walks into our
hospital right after the guy's like hey
are you from the tv's like can i just
get this for pain i need to see id
i would like to know are you putin plant
from tv show no i just sleep on ice it's
fine it happens
you got girly clawed face
[Laughter]
why did you let him do that to you
that's embarrassing it looks like you
have acne but it's really just your skin
it's really just your nails by boy your
skin mars like peach are you sure you're
not walking cabbage pitch doll
after seeing this do you honestly think
ukraine and russia aren't going to fight
one another
you imagine having it was a civil
conversation
so mad this is not gonna happen
i feel like if right now tokunawan just
front kicked dave to the face you just
saw his foot come in and then dave jumps
over and pummels him and then afterwards
have to sit here and joke about john
oliver right now right that guy's so
silly look i promise we're not gonna
actually invade we're just fighting on
air like all right they really hate each
other that's a good example of how this
is going to end yeah exactly and here we
call it an insurrection if some people
just like walk in because they're
invited into the white house you imagine
those people could you imagine those
people capitol building picture this i
don't know the i'm sorry what did i say
white house yeah white house sorry uh
capitol building the canadians burnt
down the white house to get to them in a
second jerks but the thing is
imagine okay imagine those people and i
don't know what the provinces are states
are in ukraine exactly okay right but
imagine if let's say at one in the
morning
those guys in ukraine went to bed where
their state had been called for one guy
and then woke up at 3 00 a.m yeah and
all of a sudden like wait 160 000 votes
change in one hour how do you think they
would have approached totally fine
they're elected representatives
should we should have pulled the clip
from eastern promises yes exactly
it would have been so many magazines
loading they could have done a song like
the blue man group yes just a barber
shop clip clip clip
it's jingle bells yes okay it's good
time no we kill prime minister don't do
it i'm saying them in the uk i know i
know i'm just saying the point is we
shouldn't have a prime minister is what
i'm saying we are so
no
i see an empty space
because i shot his face oh should just
be a chair yes exactly and underneath we
i didn't know this sponge was supposed
to be where no i don't know whoopsy
dupsy
head is on fire
[Laughter]
okay let's go to judd oliver he was on
with uh stephen colbert
oh boy oh dear you have allergies no
that's just my hate getting out
it climbs out of your throat it climbs
out
sorry not sorry the game so over the
weekend john oliver was almost stephen
colbert i first off
how much unfunny can you fit in the room
well they try apparently all of it yes
you tell jokes like a girl yes you
scratch each other unfunny seems to
congregate there so uh they were talking
about how comedians are no longer in
absolute despair now that trump this is
something i don't understand now that
trump is out of office because
first off i remember when conservatives
thought oh when trump is office we don't
have anything to make fun of any more
like barack obama and i never felt that
way because i knew that the media the
entertainment industry establishment
they were really the they were the enemy
they were the people right they were the
establishment we were railing against
not who's in the white house and of
course now can't stand former vice
president joe biden but i'm not in
despair so i don't understand how john
oliver and stephen colbert don't
acknowledge that trump was a gift for
them comedically because they can't
write yeah without trump in office every
story was trump right and for proof that
they can't write watch their show today
and then notice the only clips that get
any kind of play is when they reference
trump
still only use trump right all they've
they've made fun of trump for the last
year because all they can do is push
propaganda for uh former vice president
joe biden so here's john oliver saying
he's no longer an absolute despair now
that trump's out of office with unfunny
color how has the doing the show felt
during this administration as opposed to
the last one because certainly i feel a
great difference in my
in
my daily focus it's much it's much more
fun to do right it's something it's not
fun writing comedy from
absolute despair uh and and for us it's
been it was so much even we were getting
ourselves getting sucked into dealing
with the fire hose of what was coming
out that administration all the time so
it is nice to return to do what we do
best i think which is stories about pace
loans okay hold on a second i know
they're english so they don't pronounce
their arsenal right what did he just say
can we rewind that and see what he just
said in that last part
it is nice to return to do what we do
best i think which is stories about pace
loans stories about taste loans hey uh
you know what control
that smells like ratatouille can we uh
control room can we figure out exactly
let's get let's find out what he said
here yeah let's
uh tokuno what do you got what did he
say
uh nothing stephen okay all right i
didn't understand that okay yeah
um
we'll cover it tomorrow john oliver he
did a whole segment on critical race
theory we'll cover that tomorrow
what are you still oh you're still
looking on your phone trying to figure
it out it just doesn't exist it doesn't
exist no did you say pace loans i don't
know what that is
loans
we pronounce it properly it's all
alphabet really no
how do you how do you say r ah are you
hurt
yeah it is rough well one you you don't
write comedy from absolute despair you
write it from looking back on it right
you know tragedy plus time right now i
would call it the tragedy yes if i'm
just judging by you know bank accounts
jobs you know whatever whatever bank
account employment you know i mean if
you're looking at it that way right you
know but unbelievable debt yes pete
buttgig has a job in government right
there's uh
uh you know
blackface hitler right but you know
whatever
no i understand but that's not make a
strong case no and you know there's
mostly war about to break out not only
just between two guys on tv but you know
right not too concerned they'll just
scratch each other like girls no it's
fine uh and we'll and he has a critical
race theory segment john oliver that
just went up we're going to do a
rebuttal to that tomorrow because yeah
everything this guy put and i think john
oliver can be funny but at what point
and please you guys can comment at what
point does comedy become propaganda look
and it's not lost on me
uh that i have a point of view but i'm
very open about it and we try to let you
know you know all references are
available at lyderworthcrowder.com we
provide those in the description i think
it's pretty easy to tell when you see a
patch adam's penis doctor sketch or dave
and i making a a joke about men fighting
in the ukraine scratching like girls
although that's actually that actually
happened it did um
so did the patch adam sketch
allegedly
that happened so that was a real that's
a real doctor yeah he's as
he's an md so technically if you want to
get you know none of it but you know
he's as accurate as many doctors have
been yes exactly
laughter is the best med and ooh he's
dead
so
i don't know when does it become
propaganda i i really do wonder at a
certain point when you see john oliver
and they're using sources like
slate salon well let's get to this guy
jordan clepper who i found out did have
a show on comedy central it was
cancelled so now trevor noah is carrying
his water hey by the way uh token allen
did trevor noah ever
because trevor noah when we were on air
said yeah he wanted to come on the show
what's is he is he coming on the show i
don't think we haven't gotten a message
back yet he said like the our the
management his management will be his
people will be in touch with our people
um so we got in touch with him and said
yes yeah he said why don't you have me
on so we said yes and now i have no idea
ah oh okay so well somebody who is
watching the last time tell him this
time yeah let's go mr noah if you're
drunk texting we welcome them again now
it's probably over pretty early twitter
is getting fired right
i didn't say that
i don't know if that's south africa
that's a close i don't know what it is i
don't know what it is i i don't know
everything about him is just
ugly i mean internally i'll admit my
impressions of [ __ ] much like his show
i don't even know how to do it trevor no
impression honestly because it's just i
don't think about him i don't know how
to do an impression of this next guy
jordan clipper so jordan klepper is i
guess a correspondent to the daily show
and don't you love how with the daily
show the worst correspondents got their
own shows like samantha b and trevor
noah they were never the standout
correspondents no there's great ones on
there they're great funny comics i mean
when you think they had steve carell was
a correspondent when you think rob
riggle was a correspondent stephen
colbert was a correspondent uh uh and
helms was ed helms was a correspondent
josh gad was a correspondent uh what's
his name uh uh the other other other
other not junior as a correspondent i
think roy would just junior is funny why
would you but he didn't get a show now
he's another correspondent he should
have gotten the daily show rob cordrey
was a correspondent it was a feeder
league for talent and then the only
shows to come out of the previous daily
show with jon stewart
trevor noah samantha bee now this is a
good example
what talents have they created
what a-list talents have they where's
trevor noah's steve carell
where's samantha bee's rob riggle right
where's their rob cordray where's their
ed helms jon stewart created stars
because why he looked for people who
were funny for crying out loud rob
riggle is probably at the very
at worst he's a moderate he was a marine
and the guy is hilarious jon stewart
looked for funny first he's being
condemned for that now trevor noah and
samantha b they have to look for
propagandists first and so they
literally can't even get a guy like this
jordan clepper to have a show that's a
once a week half hour weekend show to
work on comedy central because they're
not actually looking for talent they're
not actually looking for the funniest
people that should be what matters most
instead we have diversity matters most
meaning racial diversity meaning gender
diversity and then we say what matters
most is that people have the right point
of view because we can't have
intellectual diversity and way down the
list somewhere if you look for it if you
scratch
like a pig scratching for truffles or a
ukrainian broadcaster scratching the
face of a putin plant you maybe find
talent and funny there so here's jordan
klepper comedian right comedians who are
supposed to be
the voice against authority right um
going down
yes though right comedy samantha bee
where they killed conan the
last funny late night show host just
gonna point that out but they also
murdered him yes well that's great it's
just the prime minister of finland tbs
decided one day that they were a comedy
station right yeah exactly and we were
supposed to believe it sorry tnt next
year
thank walking dead and uh well uh trevor
noah now uh plays with a hand puppet
yeah let's take conan off the air and
then we'll leave everything else great
good call reruns of tyler perry
okay oh boy pretty much all tyler perry
shows they're reruns let's be honest
let's see i tune in like it's the exact
same show oh someone goes to the dentist
they're scared and they don't want to
and then they come back and they learn
about life pretty much the character
rerun
okay
so jordan klepper went down to the
canadian freedom convoy and you would
think speak out against authority speak
out against the police who are abusing
protesters right because this is a guy
you know who supported the black instead
he went down to the freedom convoy
to crap remember people say don't punch
down they say we're punching down when
we go after lgbtq aip or dave chappelle
does right i can't think of anything
more punching down than literally going
to a protest where people have had their
rights
infringed upon have been locked down
have their businesses shut down and
mocking them but that's what jordan
klepper said is the ticket for him the
trucker convoy has arrived in ottawa
this city in the downtown core remains
gridlocked some residents here say that
they really can take
no more so i traveled to ottawa
expecting to find some canada nice but
their messaging was a bit more coarse
these trucks shut down businesses and
made roads impassable why did you blur
that out when the
maple leaf was already blurring out the
f word well no because they want to make
sure that you think it's more aggressive
oh yeah yeah because it seems painfully
obvious they were doing that right
because unlike black lives matter who
just going like hey we're going to burn
the walgreens down at eight sounds good
these people cleverly had the f oh maple
leaf ck trudeau because you know just
like let's go brandon right they don't
want you know most of these people they
have jobs and children different strokes
only canadians are like hey we're not
that maddie yeah we're not well we're
not going to use we are that mad but you
know we're not going to be we're not
going to become animals we're not going
to use this sort of coarse language
by the way you scratch like a girl you
know
i'm not sure buddy so he he there
complains
these p these people shut down business
hold on a second
so that bothers you yeah they shut down
businesses do you mean like
prime minister trudeau locked down shut
down business which by the way resulted
in three million jobs lost another 200
000 lost in january and canada only has
what is it that we got do we it's like
30 something million million people 30
something mil that's almost 10
of canada lost their jobs wow that's
crazy but you're mad because of a few
trucks
on a highway overpass
okay so
again this is just right black lives
matter they sit there they kneel they
talk about how important it is if you if
look you can go back and just well you
can't search it on youtube but on mug
club steven crowder black lives matter
trevor
you'll see we've covered it many times
and they were supportive of it well how
many businesses did black lives matter
shut down i mean we're talking about
troops now it's burned uh well burn burn
yeah or shut down i believe there was a
car lot or two yes well or had the same
owner or they just ransacked them or
made them unsafe for patrons to go out
like do you do not see the connection
well cup foods is the real loser in all
this well they really are yeah i call it
a clearance sale yes
a 999 dollar but no more no no clearance
sales we have standards
yeah please just like when you go to the
t-shirt rack and you get last year's
political it's like oh mitt happens with
the picture of mitt romney well it's the
same thing only a burn down of walgreens
and you take you know 900 worth of
equipment you know bad i want a mitt
happens shirt
now we're going to sell it at
crowdershop.com
so then he moves on
to interview and this is sort of just a
selective editing that you see right to
uh find one person in a crowd who seems
crazy and the funny thing is this guy
doesn't seem all that crazy when you
take it in context uh and implies that
they're just paranoid so here's jordan
klepper doing the people's work you're
committed to be being here for two years
yeah because two years is nothing how
are you going to keep up the energy to
be here for two problems people bring
stimulants no the people bring it i
smoke a lot of weed yeah okay right yeah
but that's just to calm me down and keep
me keep me centered are you worthy at
all with weed paranoia that might creep
in no no no
do you think the government is coming
for you
oh yeah constantly they they're like
might night little tactics they try to
they move around they move in they add
more are you paranoid no
sure okay so first off it's funny that
this is a guy who's obviously been pro
weed in the past you can go and research
his uh pieces in the past and i'm not
really high right now yeah he's probably
high right there but he says you're not
parrot he's he's trying to of course
this implication when you don't make an
argument right if someone just says yeah
i think the government's coming after me
oh but you're not paranoid that's just
it's like fred penner
let me explain
i have to play fred penner for my twins
mm-hmm
i i don't know how that guy ever got a
job it's just lazy songwriting
fred penner it wasn't child friendly she
was like i got a mug got a mug and oh no
there's a bug in my mug but it's not so
i'm gonna drink from my mug fred
penner's place you should be fired
it's lazy
it's for freaking six-month-olds who is
freddie
i don't even know i don't want to talk
about it it's gonna make me mad my point
is get some raffi in your life son it's
lazy lazy arguing and he just assumes
that an uneducated audience will go oh
yeah paranoid the government's going to
come after him well i guess those
viewers viewer of the show or the jordan
klepper segments or you know jordan
clepper segments on trevor noah as
they're common you know what they're
referred to in the nielsen ratings
what's that they referred to as piss
break ah so the jordan klepper segment
um
[Laughter]
i guess the viewers maybe didn't
actually track down this clip of the
crazy ottawa police chief uh saying that
even if protesters go home
after this in other words not just right
now yeah if protesters go home or anyone
who's been involved with these protests
at all
and you're going to see this in a second
and i hope it's as terrifying to you as
it is to me that this is happening in
the western world he says afterwards
they will be tracked down and punished
no mention of due process if the
protesters at this point
you know
retreat and go home
are they going to be getting sort of
repercussions down the road are you
going to be sort of actively pursuing
the people that you've been sort of
documenting and filming who are still
out there protesting what are your plans
after this after the protest is over
thank you it's a great question and the
simple answer is yes
if you are involved in this protest we
will actively look to identify you and
follow up with financial sanctions and
criminal charges absolutely
this investigation will go on for months
to come it has many many different
streams both from a federal uh financial
level from a provincial licensing level
from a criminal code level from a
municipal breach of court order breach
of court and junction level right and
marty mcfly's playboy level yes
that is terrifying and by the way first
off this isn't even smart because you're
not giving these people an out what do
you think is going to happen do they
want these people to become violent
because when you say hey by the way you
made your voices hears her hurt and you
protested and nobody was hurt we're
going to harm you once you leave it's
insane a part of me wonders if they're
trying to get people to say well there's
nothing to lose now that's if you want
peace you give somebody an out by the
way the out would have just been okay
you don't have to show a a vaccine
passport to go to a restaurant that
would have been a nice out but at least
at this point give them an out where if
you go home we're not going to freeze
your bank accounts and harm your family
and this is something else that i but
again it's just crazy paranoia
for crying out loud alex jones is
seeming more and more like an oracle if
alex jones were to tell you this not
long ago listen here's what's going to
happen you're going to show up and if
you even so much as protests at the
capitol they will freeze your bank
accounts yeah freeze your banking let's
go for your family and they will follow
you to the ends of the earth trust me i
have seen the camps
or in canada i have seen the camps you
know
i've been around i know what i'm talking
about i know what i'm talking about
um
and this is also something where i you
know a lot of conservatives abandon
public schools they abandon right public
office so the police chief before this
guy left resigned before this now i
understand probably i don't know why i'm
inferring here okay just to be clear i
don't want to do propaganda i'm letting
you know that i'm making
this is this is conjecture
probably didn't want to be involved with
the uh complete destruction of basic
human rights in canada but the problem
is if you abandon your post a lot of
conservatives
they leave these places they concede
that territory guess what
trudeau or whoever is in charge of that
office whatever patsy for the higher ups
can plant whoever they want there and
now you've got a guy who's going to do
the bidding for that government and
follow people after the protests
to punish them yeah well just think
about this for a second because they're
saying like you said in alex jones voice
you know freezing your bank accounts
like seriously that is happening to
people right now who are doing nothing
more than protesting and by protesting i
mean parking a truck in downtown ottawa
and dancing right that's it well they're
pretty white protest well the dance
moves i will say the black doesn't
matter protests they were better they
were much better for that also the style
points in front of the giant fires but
just imagine right now if you're a small
business owner and you have no access to
capital let's say you were expanding
let's say you're trying to run your
small business let's say you're trying
to try to pay your freaking rent and
they're like oh hey by the way your
account's frozen when will i get it back
when we get around and by the way this
is how you affect protesters who are
employed or want to be employed whereas
with other protesters in the summer of
love guess what there was a rent
moratorium it's like we're going to
freeze your money i don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah and if you've ever dealt with
any government agency or like the dmv
you definitely want to take care of your
bank account yes i'm waiting on a tax
refund that is over a year and a half
late yes well yeah i'm waiting for the
audit final that's been taken two years
yes i didn't do anything wrong well you
know what they'll find something it's
awesome well but to go back to the
trucker even part of that when he said
when is it propaganda you go into a
place that's freezing cold you find a
guy who's scared he's never been on
camera before clearly he's a little bit
twitchy he's a little bit nervous he's
never been interviewed like that in that
situation you find the exact guy who
you're mocking because you know you can
that's when it stops being comedy and
begins to be propaganda and by the way
because it's punching yes and it doesn't
even work because the guy's right oh
wait you mean he's paranoid that the
government might come after him i wonder
where he could have seen that within a
five block radius of where you
interviewed him
oh you're saying there's more and more
police what what a crazy guy
what a loon
we're being arrested
man being kneed there totally makes
sense this is all over uh virus
it's for your health dave come on true
come on true
what is happening here just riding
horses
[Applause]
i'm sure there were clydesdales by
accident
oh that's totally normal
[Music]
[Applause]
now here's the thing i understand that
horses this happens sometimes it's an
accident you guys should clear but what
were they they were clearing a path for
what no reason all that happened was the
horses went by and you go okay who are
they what is it an ambulance behind them
because you know when black lives matter
remember
some people died because they were in
houses and the the uh they would buy
ambulances yeah yeah the fire trucks
couldn't get there yeah i thought oh
we're gonna see a fire truck those
horses just they just went through just
for a good old-fashioned trampoline this
was a parade steven they have to get out
of the way of the parade and i love a
parade yeah and they're not going to
rain on it nope
nope it's raining horseshoes that's
right hallelujah is a rain shoe so i
guess it's paranoid you think the
government might come after i don't know
businesses that we've seen with the
canadian government of course that maybe
they'll come in or maybe it's paranoid
this crazy little guy right uh jordan
clipper the bully that you are maybe
it's crazy for canadians to be paranoid
that the government might come after i
don't know um pastors
[Music]
seems like an unsafe place to arrest a
pastor
in the road
any place is an unsafe place to arrest a
pastor what racial conditions
you're out of your house david
right yes yeah so you were released you
had some conditions
did you have conditions what conditions
what did i do what did i breathe
is this way seems reasonable
is that a black cop now i've seen
everything
in canada
you took an oath
no better than the nazis by the way that
cop and the police chief in canada
should be stripped of their badges like
officer and a gentleman just oh yeah
they were just doing their jobs well
deserved yeah and that man should be
carried out like so yes
just where we belong
oh boy where the horse is stomp oh no
and the syrup drifts
and the serp flows
[Laughter]
okay we get it we'll do more on mug club
now
also i don't know maybe the government
could force quarantines the point is
it's not paranoia if it's ha
ning it's like somebody reading me and
me saying i don't know i'm paranoid that
there's a i'm paranoid that there's
tepid tea in that moment he's like oh
really you just think there's gonna be
yeah because it appears almost every
morning i have a horse stomp your rib
cage in and go are you paranoid yeah
paranoid does that feel a little
paranoid i think i think you collapsed
my lung no no that's just that paranoia
it's that phantom lung paranoia you were
in the way they were trying to get over
there for no reason yes
you were in the way of what
they're stomping yeah yeah because
that's how this is their stomping ground
that's how you calm down a crowd by
trampling some of the peaceful
protesters who weren't doing anything in
the fight and kneeing them for crying
out loud there's rules in the ufc you
can't knee the head of a downed opponent
stop resisting just ask algebra and
sterling and peter yawn he's bleeding on
me again people who watch the
lightweights fight the best way to clear
a group of people is to come out of
nowhere and say excuse me move and then
just immediately go in and not care
right yes i've always said that although
you know what that being said what i
would like to see
is someone just march on in in with a
budweiser clydesdale into a walgreens or
someone's having the old five finger
discount ah are you sure these razor
bump lotions happen to be my stomping
grounds and then you have them do the
arabian horse yeah
they're very well trained horses just
roll a magnum on it and be like you sure
you want to do that yes
all right my horse wants to get to know
you now i think this is pretty telling
watch jordan clap because this is the
language of a comedian right an
anti-authoritarian
come on just think about this they
called donald trump a fascist they said
oh it could be under an authoritarian
regime you are talking about specif
there has never been a more clear
example maybe australia
in the western world of a tyrant
than trudeau
this
i mean this man is not going to stop no
he's not going to stop he doesn't care
about your freedoms
and they don't have the same
constitution that we have here in the
united states remember when you all
mocked jordan peterson about the
compulsion of language well guess what
here's where we are now
you don't think that this guy who can
arrest people and freeze their bank
accounts
for parking their truck
can arrest you for using the wrong
pronouns of course he would this is
getting absolutely terrifying and i'll
explain to you exactly why
uh the left is now covering this because
they ignored it for a long time i'll
explain to you exactly why jordan
klepper feels the need to punch down he
really is a patsy for the higher ups i
bet you this came to him as orders from
viacom uh he uses this word here
finally and just
just hear when he says finally and
understand
why it sends shivers up my spine and
while canadian authorities have finally
enacted emergency measures to try to
clear the convoy so far the trucks are
still there finally
while he's finally enacted emergency
orders
that's a finally of support
yeah and of course taken in context i
recommend that you go watch this entire
clip i think it's over to the whatever
the comedy central channel um
they finally enacted emergency orders
hey remember bill hicks remember lenny
bruce remember george carlin remember
people talking about how the government
wasn't equipped to do anything and now
this comedian right is demanding
not only fewer rights for himself right
unless it's having sex with a dude
that's what they consider right having
sex with a dude killing an unborn baby
all the way up until including birth but
when you're talking about things like
basic rights you know finally the prime
minister has made sure that he can ban
travel
in the country of canada to and from
specific areas force evacuation of
people and property that means steal
people and steal property force private
companies like tow trucks to comply loss
of personal commercial licenses he'll
just strip you of them loss of right to
travel internationally at all let alone
within the borders fines of up to a
hundred thousand dollars by the way from
the government to the truckers and then
fines of five thousand dollars to people
who don't move the trucks
jail up to five years
jail up to five years for parking a
truck
you know when people say insurrection
january 6th i'll tell you what
this is this is a far greater greater
tragedy than january 6 and it's what the
government is doing to its own people
because guess what even when there is no
january 6 you stomp them
sure babbitt was shot
was the only person shot by the way
january 6 one woman unarmed shot
completely unnecessary let's be clear as
far as i know having the same charges of
insurrection against those people here
we have
protesters in canada who've been
entirely peaceful contrast with billions
of dollars in damages from black lives
matter right an antifa
how many people were shot in chaz at
least three would have been five if our
producers were shot when we were filming
their live
and the government still beats the [ __ ]
out of them hits them with night sticks
stomps them
with horses let alone freezing their
bank accounts and letting them know that
they will continue to ruin their
livelihoods for the rest of time should
they deem fit this is far worse than
january 6. you want to blame january 6th
insurrectionists
for for
for destroying faith in our institutions
hey you know what destroys faith in your
institutions when your institutions act
like and use animals
to harm your own citizens
is that what's supposed to happen when
people go oh look at what's happening oh
the americans are boston tea party
they're losing faith in their
institutions yeah well it's not really
losing faith if your institution sucks
yeah well you have a weak tyrant in
justin trudeau and that's a problem if
somebody is tyrannical and they're weak
they're going to do things like this to
prove that they're not weak hitler was a
weak tyrant in the initial beginning of
his phase right he was weak he was not a
strong person mussolini was always weak
always a way better tell any speaker
though well yeah i'm just saying that's
true but it's you talk about it with the
kind of weak men right if they're put in
this situation they have to violently
react whereas strongmen know that they
can handle the situation and they're
good to go they don't have to show that
force until later yeah with guys like
trudeau nobody's shaking his hands
nobody thinks he's a part of the cool
club nobody likes justin trudeau and
he's a weak tyrant who's like okay i've
got to do something scared dogs bite
exactly scared dogs bite people often
come up they're afraid they're terrified
of joe lewis joe lewis has never even
come close to knowing anybody because
he's confident little dogs are afraid
and what they they've got to bite
because i've got to put you on your toes
right away i've got a scar on my
achilles that proves it that little
bichon prick
now the rest of this segment uh he goes
on to basically just selectively edit a
little thing was like cujo was like a
four pound cujo bit my achilles snapped
it
are you serious yeah i hate it i mean i
killed it
well yeah oh geez so um
i mean i didn't kill it it was your
tiger blood i just had my at the time my
great dane just stomp it
needed a clear path
i ride around uh joe lewis like that yes
my horse yeah i know that all right you
can do that and he just we go through
parades of people you can just your feet
don't even touch the ground
so then he goes on this jordan clepper
he goes on to just basically selectively
edit to try and make people on the
street look crazy and he continues with
this general i guess sort of malfeasance
and degradation of canadian truckers uh
but again it's still pretty telling let
me show you the end of it and a
well-funded never-ending street party
infused with misinformation and
nationalism feels remarkably possible in
our own land of the free
where does this movement go he always
needs that cocaine worldwide it's going
to come to america yes definitely do you
think this is inspiring the heads of
america part of me this is inspiring the
heads of america it's inspiring
people
people of america see you're a piece of
[ __ ] and they're polite to stand for
freedom okay
if they do come to america then maybe
i'll finally get my [ __ ] end table
okay so two things almost say whated yes
exactly sorry no exactly it's opposite
day that's what he did though it's it's
really pathetic it's the oppo it's the
absence of wit here's something notice
when we did uh the riots they started
yeah we streamed that night and over 150
000 of you were watching when the riots
started the peaceful protest all we did
was show you what was happening across
the country right didn't even require
that much commentary we showed you cnn
where it said mostly peaceful this
happened live on our show and now it's
sort of become a meme because everyone
else saw saw what was going on said
fiery but mostly peaceful protests we
just showed you exactly what was going
on okay in this case
you don't think for a second if this guy
could find an example of violence or
insurrection or something on fire or a
crime being committed that he would
include it he can't so he has to say uh
[ __ ] in america and he's corrected
by the nice people being interviewed you
know mothers who aren't used to being on
camera saying well we hope that it
inspires people and this is the point
why are they addressing this now i'll
tell you exactly why they're addressing
this now they are afraid that this could
be a groundswell and that it could come
to the united states because yes the
supply chain has been disrupted that is
a wonderful way to peacefully protest
and make your voices heard because
you're not
directly burning down somebody's
business what you are doing is forcing
the government to well if they had any
sense take a seat at the table and
listen this is how most great
civil rights protests have taken place
and by the way yeah we're not just
talking about civil rights we are
talking about basic human rights but
this is make no mistake a civil rights
protest
regardless of color and it's it's a
mixed crowd canada so it's not quite as
mixed as you know anywhere outside of
canada but it's still as mixed as you're
going to have in canada they are afraid
of this coming to the states and i have
said this many times
i hope it does
i would love to see a freedom trucker
convoy here in the united states yeah
absolutely i would love to see that here
in the united states especially if it's
as peaceful as it was in canada i know i
would love to see a freedom convoy here
in the united states that's a peaceful
way to have an impact
and now of course they have to address
it by the way i'm pretty sure that's the
show trevor noah was watching
i think so or the day before call them
out yeah but what are we supposed to do
protest in an ineffective way is that
what sit-ins were back when you were
fighting for civil rights when you took
over the wisconsin state house and
basically just all sat in there it's an
effective way of getting in the way and
making yourself the impediment well
they're doing the same thing with trucks
that's it right what do you want them to
okay here here's the deal i got a
question for you truckers you want to do
this instead of clogging downtown ottawa
go and sit on the side of every single
road in canada and still don't deliver
packages and goods still effective what
are they going to do to you then oh well
now you're just you're block we're not
blocking a thing you can get down into
ottawa if you would like we're just not
doing the job that will make you feel
the pain well let me just tell you i
don't want them to do that i want them
to continue i do i want them to do both
but i don't want justin trudeau's
hatchet men going in there beating
people up and stealing money from their
bank accounts shutting down financial
institutions for just funding people and
didn't have a problem with doing it for
black lives matter but have a problem
doing it with people raise money for
serial felons with black lives matter
absolutely well cutting off all funding
taking all their money away
it's just absolutely amazing that
anybody could be on the side of that for
peacefully let alone comedians comedians
and you're talking about lenny bruce and
carlin like lenny bruce and carlin if
people don't know were arrested together
once right for stuff like this yeah i'm
not saying that they were conservative
but look at course i'm different like
look at the timeline this has nothing to
do with politics anymore right this is
being taken over by a government right
everything's stolen from you yeah why
would you ever be on the side of that
but you can go d like harlow would sit
there and go [ __ ] says what right to
an elderly woman who doesn't even yeah
oh that's what oh no it's for people
there for people no no no no we didn't
say no we didn't say [ __ ] that's
what you said out there we're saying you
know we want to we want you know them to
have a movement so [ __ ] no stop
using foul language well he's not he's
not even educated enough about the joke
that he's telling because he said
because if you guys end up coming here i
might actually i'm sorry he's an unfunny
piece of [ __ ] i'll say that that's
his show got cancelled and so he has to
so he has to you know be a lackey for
trevor and you would think trevor no
isn't he from south africa wouldn't you
think you just go like hey look just so
you know
i kind of have the inside lane on what
happens with unfettered government power
it doesn't end yeah come on trevor why
don't you just do your job and let this
guy know that ah you know what maybe we
don't want to pick on these protesters
also you know what you want to know
something else when people say hey
facebook twitter youtube they can do
whatever they want they go free speech
is only when the government doesn't when
liberals say this and by the way of
course that's that's that's untrue when
you look at section 230 because the
government and twitter facebook youtube
right they're one of the same when
they're enacting policies of the
government they've said we want more
curtailing of speech online as we just
saw recently from susan wojcicki but
even then it's not an argument that the
left actually believes in because right
now when you actually have the
government of canada
arresting and punishing people for
speech
you're fine with it anyway so don't act
just like when people say oh what about
dreamer children fun fun time dreamer
children let's say they can all stay
would you would you get rid of right can
we evict can we kick out all of the
illegal criminals who are overcrowding
our prisons can we get rid of sanctuary
cities well no well then don't say that
you care about the kids who are here the
anchor babies because that's not what
it's about when you say abortion right
they go what about rape and incest okay
if we allowed all abortions for rape and
incest would you be well no well then
don't say it's about rape and incest
don't say it's about individual
platforms being able to ban whatever
speech they want and it's not
technically censorship because you're
fine with it when the government does it
anyway and i know that in canada they
don't have freedom of speech which is
what you would like to bring here to the
united states but let's not act like if
we cross that bridge you're going to
have a problem with it then you only
demand fewer rights and less speech i've
never seen it in my lifetime if you're
on the same page as me smash that like
button smash the like button if you have
never seen in your lifetime
people in our generation people are
supposed to flip the bird to figures of
authority
doing their bidding like we are seeing
right now
well it's not even about
in every situation simon about what it
is about like you've talked about rape
and says we know where i stand on it but
it's about not going on
well
i've already got the royal family sorry
oh no no no no well that would just be
radio incest um
but you repeat yourself yeah
that's just well really take out the
rape uh you mustn't use synonyms it
makes you sound redundant it's
inarticulate by incest if you mean love
yes true love yes love is love
yes the old tale that she shall only be
awakened by true incest kiss my sister
mother wife is a beautiful girl i uh
there's a difference between that and
doing a tick tock video of your planned
parenthood punch card i mean that's the
problem is it's all these extremes that
everybody wants they want to be rewarded
for the most awful things in the entire
world that's what i don't get right
everybody wants to be rewarded for this
it's it's this pride in nothing well
here's the thing and that's actually a
good transition because uh the left is
rewarded for the most extreme right
governor ralph northam's saying well
we'd keep the baby comfortable and
survive and abortion then decide what we
want to do with it they believe in
abortion up until and including birth
period right they're against heartbeat
bills where a baby has its own heart and
we know that this is now an autonomous
life you can't argue the science of it
right they want to shout their abortion
that's pretty extreme right they want to
freeze the funds of truckers that's
pretty extreme now on the flip side bill
maher who absolutely is a liberal
just to be clear and now is i i hate to
say i i want to support him now because
i know he stepped on a limb but he is
getting a taste of his own medicine
because he did accuse the tea party
movement and people who were against
barack obama of being racist for a long
time and now he's getting the same kinds
of accusations because he said something
he's the only person in late night right
now who says anything even remotely
reasonable yeah again not nearly as
extreme as the left what you just saw
with trevor noah and jordan klepper but
he's being excoriated for it so let me
read you some of these tweets but real
quick at least he's remained a comedian
yes that's the thing i like about bill
maher and a lot like he's been a com
comedian first right that's who you
should go to for comedy not every bit of
news right no you're absolutely right so
this is actually people were upset and
i'll show you what they were upset they
were upset about bill maher speaking out
against communism in china oh and
genocide ah and uh we'll get to that in
a second how dare you
right so let me read some tweets from
you this uh the palmer report tweeted at
this point bill maher holds numerous
conservative views and few liberal views
he's therefore by definition now a
conservative liberals didn't lose the
plot he did brooklyn dad tweeted bill
maher lost me a long time ago we'll be
sure to read your letter and i don't
think he's a liberal i got sick of his
islamophobic stick and whining when his
audience didn't laugh at his quote jokes
okay again i don't think there's ever
been someone who's gone more of
a consistent anti-christian tirade than
bill maher but he has even handed he
also goes after islam i say fine look
doesn't mean that i agree with him never
once
my faith is what defines me i've been
very clear about that gerald your faith
is what defines you have you ever once
wanted bill maher off the air for him
mocking jesus or christ no not at all no
i just don't like some of it but i'm
just like whatever that's fine he had he
had an islamic expert on to talk about
why he had a problem with islam yeah he
had to tape his hands to the bottom of
the desk because they didn't want him to
ah yes wow they didn't want him to reach
out with the old cutting knife he didn't
come on barefoot from what i understand
yes exactly
completely
yes
so while i was watching uh the show this
weekend i couldn't help but notice
and keep in mind too i have been in
communication i've told this inside
baseball with people at bill maher a
while back they they reached out for me
to be on the show and then didn't have
me on the show
uh
i don't blame you
but they they did i remember the booker
specifically asked me about like the
russia scandal i was like i don't really
want to talk about the russia scandal i
said i think the oscar's so white
thing's pretty funny like well we don't
really do that we want to talk about
russia like yeah i'm probably not for
you so
um
he covered the olympics eileen gui
covered uh quite a few topics here and
there are striking similarities between
what we
what we covered how we covered exactly
how we covered it
last week two three weeks ago and him
covering it yesterday
i want you to comment below if you see
uh that maybe it goes beyond coincidence
because i've got like four or five
examples here let's first start with
eileen coo us and uh him him and us i'm
sure you've heard about american citizen
eileen goo the beautiful model
influencer and now gold medal winning
skier who was born and raised here in
america but who chose to ski in the
olympics for china cool huh
is it is is that cool now
choose to represent a totalitarian
police state over america so can you
really blame 18 year old eileen goo
who's already made over 31 million
dollars as the face of 23 brand products
in china america's best freestyle skier
eileen gu
gu
gu
go also go stealthers that's what i'm
made of
oh she won
for breakfast she won't be downing the
stars and stripes but uh
this is an american the sickle and
hammer here you go
born in san francisco to an american
father and a chinese mother eileen
announced in 2019 that she would ski for
china at the beijing games she decided
to uh ski for china in uh 2019 so she
was preparing for the 2020 yeah so
here's a quote i've decided to compete
for china in the upcoming 2022.
read it like goo i have decided to
compete for china
this was an incredibly tough decision
for me to make but here's the thing the
question is why like why would she do
that if she could ski in the united
states and for the us and still win gold
medals right she's inc deals with
victoria's secret tiffany iwc and uh of
course beats by dre very big in china
but she has 23 endorsement deals from
chinese companies including just a few
bank of china china mobile and
mgnu i have no idea how to pronounce
that but here's the interesting part
each one of those deals is worth roughly
about two and a half million dollars
by the way do we have the
we don't have the victoria's secret
catalog you can just get one for anyone
who wants on the studio i don't want one
okay
i have four in my backpack uh i'll give
you the chinese edition okay yes
it's more of a messenger bag really yeah
i come with hidings of great tits now
here's something you guys see that's
just one example
here's another example of some that we
made fun of and then bill maher
addressed uh which had not been
addressed anywhere on late night uh
comedy at this point as far as i know
but i'm not
i mean i'm not omnipresent i can't watch
all of them at the same time yeah uh the
uh the steel cooling plant in the
olympics and the facade the blazing
saddles down here you go bill maher and
then us we knew they were [ __ ]
countries but who knew there was a shell
superpower
but
on the flip side though um even though
this has been a huge propaganda campaign
the chinese you know um the topography
is something really special it is a
beautiful backdrop there in the yeah
it's a beautiful place hey we've got
some cooling towers it looks like a
water park in front of the simpsons
intro yeah let's put the ski jump there
okay so now that's true that's just a
coincidence keep in mind this is all one
segment in bill maher yeah like these
are these are chronological i think even
all the clips that we're addressing
maybe one it doesn't matter here's
something else where he addresses peng
schwein you remember pengshui yeah
no no no no we don't remember
that's all we don't remember until until
feng shui showed back up peng shui the
tennis star who disappeared we covered
it on our show a while ago and then bill
maher made very similar jokes
last night a democracy based on freedom
and they are an authoritarian
surveillance date based on how'd you
like to disappear for a few months
like that uh tennis player who recently
vanished for a while when she said she'd
been raped by a government official the
former tennis star i don't know if you
saw this too but peng shui she was even
planted in the stands to actually cheer
on gu as she won that's how i decorated
my living room everything is totally
yeah everything's totally fine i don't
know if you remember that this was the
person who basically accused one of the
chinese communist party leaders of
sexual assault she disappeared for a
while and went to i guess a re-education
camp because she came back and said oh i
never actually said that these guys are
fantastic she was being sexually
assaulted right then there was actually
a chinese official with his hand up her
rear going clap clap clap
so there's three
i'm gonna let you guys comment um and
then the final one i've been writing for
a show have you
have you been moonlighting holy [ __ ]
somebody is well
that's not the only example because now
we also have of course and look i do
appreciate that bill maher has um you
know poached somebody to address this on
his show uh here is him talking about
the uyghur camps you know who who did it
first perspective matters china has
basically jailed an entire ethnic
minority the uyghurs a situation that
both the trump and biden administrations
has called a genocide america is not
close to that we'll give you access to
our billion-plus consumers as long as
you shut up about the whole police state
genocide thing
john cena took that deal well come on
china accounts for 34 of global box
office and he's a movie star now so
like the uyghurs
last year he learned he needed to get
some re-education the uyghurs um have
been of course you know abused uh these
are muslims in china rose who have been
completely
tortured locked away uh of course uh
stripped of their rights so what did
they do they had a uyghur muslim skier
light the torch at opening ceremonies
and watched the media cover uh what a
victory this is today is cynical some
might even say sickening move by the
chinese government during its highly
choreographed opening ceremony beijing
gave the honor of being one of the two
athletes to light the olympic torch to a
member of the oppressed uyghur good for
china's far west region an ethnic
minority the chinese government is right
now committing genocide against good for
jake tapper i'm glad we found that clip
he actually called the balls and strikes
and he's dead
well where are the two maybe bilmar is
conservative i don't know what yeah
where are the two that lit the torch by
the way are they oh no no you'll never
see no they went in the torch oh i'm
sorry yeah i was gonna say they licked
them as the torch
it was like it was the wicker man yeah
they got out and just started a cattle
touching me won't bring back your honey
yeah
uh he might be conservative because he's
killed he's you know
uh anti is that what you know what so uh
from now on uh and we're gonna talk
about uh the queen having coveted uh so
you know what i appreciate that bill
maher has has
smash the like button if you want at
least to at least see more from bill
maher but maybe if i want to get the hbo
dollar dollar bills i just need a host i
just need to host this show as bill
maher yeah well
do that okay gerald oh what now gerald's
sitting there in that chair okay
you
is that cool guys i'm way more
effeminate
i know that some of you on youtube will
be offended okay
so it's time maybe for you to piss off
do